President Trump has highlighted his
administration's efforts against the
ms-13 gang so of course the left now
supports ms-13 voxcom has published a
video portraying the gang as a bunch of
cute teenagers who ride bikes listen to
music and work after-school jobs when
you think of the street gang ms-13 what
do you see
maybe something like this or this but
what if I told you the typical ms-13
gang member in the u.s. actually looks
like one of these young men on Facebook
the other 13 members that I've been
following our working after-school jobs
they're living with their parents they
get around Long Island on bicycles
there's no indication that we're seeing
a bigger surge of ms-13 then we seen in
the past
so basically ms-13 they're like high
school valedictorians with machetes
Timothy simi is the District Attorney of
Suffolk County on Long Island and the
county's former police commissioner and
he joins us Tim these guys are all over
your neck of the woods are they just
like kids doings after-school jobs
riding around on bicycles so here are
the facts in 2016 and part of 2017 we
saw 17 homicides that ms-13 committed at
17 homicides in just 16 months two of
those homicides were nice and Mickens
and Kayla Cuevas 15 and six-year-old
girls from Brentwood High School another
homicide was a quadruple homicide where
four boys were chopped into little
pieces in a park in Central Islip this
is an extremely dangerous gang I would
submit probably one of the most
dangerous street gangs that we have in
the United States
thanks to law enforcement efforts since
that time period we haven't seen a
single confirmed ms-13 homicide and
that's because of the great work of the
men and women of law enforcement in
Suffolk County now you guys have a tough
stomach for homicides but even if you're
familiar with finding dead bodies
what ms-13 do to their victims where
they actually chop off limbs and and you
find these guys dismembered it and in
pieces these are some of the most
vicious organized crime in the country
is it not
that's exactly right when they commit a
murder they do it to send a message
they're incredibly brutal one example as
I already know it was the fort for boys
in central islip there are plenty of
other examples when the two girls were
murdered in Brentwood when we first came
upon the homicide scene the injuries are
so severe we actually thought it was a
hit-and-run because the head trauma was
so significant we need to take this gang
extremely seriously that's exactly what
law enforcement is doing across the
country and I applaud everyone's efforts
we're working together to target violent
ms-13 gang members and we're making a
difference do you think it helps when
someone like Volcom which has a lot of
influence on the left basically say oh
sure there's like some people who kill
people in it but there's a lot of just
nice cute kids they're going along with
it as they might with any after-school
activity no it minimizes the threat that
this streaking that this street gang
poses and it minimizes the situation
that these communities find themselves
in ms-13 targets young Hispanic boys in
neighborhoods that are underserved it's
incredibly important important that we
target these gang members with
aggressive law enforcement tactics and
then we also invest in gang prevention
and intervention strategy so that we
prevent them from recruiting more
members good luck good luck with that
they've done some terrible things out in
your part of Long Island Tim thanks very
much for joining us thank you a night